Guys, quite a day. Quite a day. I'm excited. I woke up really excited today. I went through audio security that was really surprising. What is that like? What is that like? Well, it was a lot of ear probing.
So all the wax is out of both ears right now. Oh, finally. Yeah. I was testing my connection. Testing my connection. So all the wax is out of both of your arms right now. Oh, finally. I was testing my connection, testing my connection. But I feel like there's something really special coming. Well, it sounds like you guys are really cleaned up for today. What about you, Sean? Did you do anything?
No, I got up early because I was nervous about today. Well, you have a good right to be. It's a big, big day for us. Because of our listeners, because we're a place that really important folks like the Tim Walls campaign think that this might be a worthy stop. So thank you to you listeners. You guys made this happen and we are really excited
to talk to our next guest. So get ready. We also want to say, I know that a lot of people, you know, come and listen to Smarlist because it's a great place to kind of get away from all the noise and stuff. And giggle and snag. Yeah, but JB, you were talking,
like this is also a really good time to remind people that they need to. Yeah, that they don't need to vote, but they should vote, they could vote. We happen to have our own opinions that become pretty apparent and evident just because we're on the side of common sense, but just vote.
A lot of people hurt or killed or whatever, trying to secure that right for all of us. Let's just go use it. We only get to do it once every few years. And I think you're right. And again, it can't be said enough, which is even if you don't agree with us, that's okay, but still get out and vote.
It's still important. We all have that right. And I respect your right to do it. And you should respect mine. Did Jay, when you said common sense, do you think I have a lot of common sense? It's an all new smart list. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
Smart. Less. By the way, dinner was really good last night. Was it? Yeah, it was really good. What'd we have? Oh, I know what we had, burgers, right? Burgers, yeah. Burgers and...
Did you bring a dessert, Sean? I brought a ton of dessert. He did. Did you really? Listen, I'm not even kidding. I brought brownies, rice krispie treats, banana muffins. I'm sorry, I just want to stop and say, I thought for you, rice krispie cakes were for breakfast.
It's breakfast. That was a breakfast. Well, this is true. Well, that's the great thing about them. You can eat them any time of the day. That is the great thing about them. Isn't that? Thank time of the day. That is the great thing about them. Isn't that? Thank you. Yeah.
So, Will, you tried each one of those things. I did not have any. Oh, how about that? He's pretty disciplined about the no sugar right now. Yes, and then I told you, Will, by the time I get home, I will have a bowl of ice cream, and I did. Oh my God.
And I said to Sean, we were talking about sleep, which has been a recurring theme for us. And he was talking about his poor sleep hygiene and waking up or not being able to go to bed. And I said, what are you having at night? He goes, nothing, this'll be you. This'll be my meal. And I go, and when I get home,
I mean, I might have some ice cream. I go, well, there it is. Anyway, let's get to our guest. Yeah, whose guest is this? I've not heard this so. It's America's guest. It's America's guest. There are only a few times, probably less than five,
I don't know, on this show, this thing that we do, where the guest, all three of us know who the guest is because they're a big freaking deal. And today is one of those shows. And I speak for all three of us when I say that this is a huge honor to have him come speak with us for a bit. He's many things, all of which we'll get into shortly
from the Army National Guard to teacher to congressman to governor to so many other things. But to me, he's the quintessential all-American dad I never had. Oh, and he's also a coach, something else I could probably use in my life. Currently running to be the next vice president of the United States of America, please welcome Tim Walz.
There he is. Tim. Hi, Tim. Hello there. Well, hang on. How do you like to be addressed? Just Tim. Just Tim. Just Tim. Hello there. Well, hang on. How do you like to be addressed? Just Tim. Just Tim.
Just Tim. I stick to that. I will say this though. We did a trade mission to London and the hello governor stuff, I just lived on it for the entire week. The entire week. Hello Governor. Hello Governor.
And it wasn't ironic. It was like real. That's hysterical. It was better. Yeah, no, Tim is great. Tim, it was like real. Yes, I know, that's hysterical. It was better, yeah, no, Tim is great. Tim, I want to get, because I saw Will last night, Jay, we missed you, you were at the Dodger game. I know, I know, I'm sorry.
That's okay. I should have skipped the Dodger game, they got waxed. No, but we were talking about sleep, I always talk about sleep with these guys because I've always had trouble. And then I'm like, you got thrown into this campaign. Obviously late in the game. I can't wait to hear where this is going.
No, I want to know, it's a very dumb, Sean smartless question. Is your sleep hygiene, like you go 20, it seems like you go 24 hours a day just going for this, and then this, and this. You have to do all the work to do. Sean's worried, Tim, that you're not getting enough sleep. That's what I'm worried about, that's my question.
When do the naps happen? How do you get, where the energy comes from? Well, you know, the good thing is, old men need less sleep or whatever, I guess. Look, I do not sleep that much. I've been using this saying, it's kind of my catch thing. I said, we'll sleep when we're dead. And I had a woman come up to me and goes,
you're taking this too literally. You look like hell, man. She meant it well, but no, I'm trying. I'm always fascinated by that, by schedule. Just the schedule's full all day, every day. It's amazing. Yeah, well, it's a privilege to do it, but you're right. My daughter keeps me on this.
She got one of these rings, you know, monitor your sleep, whatever she needs, I need one of those. But I think that will just tell me what I already know. I'm not getting any sleep. That's all it'll say. Tim, let me just say this. I haven't done the ring, but I've done will just tell me what I already know. I'm not getting any sleep. That's all it'll say. Tim, let me just say this. I haven't done the ring, but I've done the Apple Watch thing, whatever.
And we'll say- The great Apple Watch. Sorry, the great Apple Watch. Jason wants a free Apple Watch. No, it's just because they're listening. Oh, don't worry, he already got it. I think it's really good stuff. I think these Apple folks are onto something.
It's great work. Tim, by the way, we should be called, not smartly, we should be called shameless. And if there's any product out there you've got your eye on it, just mention it and we'll have them send it to you. That new 16 Pro guys, it's really working. So, what I was gonna say about that,
watch those sleep tracking things. I got into it for a while. And I think your daughter's right because you go like, okay, we'll work on I, but then at the end of the day, what ends up happening is you start feeling bad. So I wake up and I go, I think I did okay, and then I'm like, oh my God, I only got three hours of REM, and then I got sleep panic.
See what I did? Yeah, yeah. It is just the thing, I think seeing, the one thing about this is there is an is an end state if you will on November 5th, so you just kind of put your mind into it and say look this there will be a time when this ends You know really that's probably not true. You think things get calm after the fifth It's the trick I play myself yeah team is good. I I'm surprisingly And you wouldn't know it by looking at me, I'm a pretty dedicated runner.
I run about five times a week. Oh, that's great. How far do you go? I go a 5K usually between three and five miles. And I'm like, for an old guy, I'm kind of freakishly fast. Nine minute miles, little less or whatever. Wow. And people are like, oh my God,
that's a world record for a man your age. But now, Tim, now you can't, well, which is, and you know, people are like, oh my God, that's a world record for a man your age. That's good. But now, Tim, now you can't, well, as governor, you had security detail. Were you running with, or were you on a treadmill? I do a treadmill quite a bit of the time, but you have to get outside, and my team knows, like, wherever, or anywhere, and actually, you know,
here a while back, after we finished that debate, the next morning, I got to run in Central Park. And it was awesome. We ran that reservoir route. Of course it was just stunning. And I'm still truly the small town guy enough, I have not spent much time in New York. It just blows me away when I'm there.
And that morning, so many great people, it was kind of good for the psyche. Oh, good job, Governor. And I'm like, oh, thank goodness. And they're, of course, super surprised I'm running too, so it was like a double positive. So, well. I like the idea of you running in Central Park,
looking around, and really, because you haven't been there a lot, taking it in, twirling around, not unlike Mary Tyler Moore did in Minneapolis. And then Mary Tyler Moore. That is surprisingly close to how it was. I think we'll make it after all. Now, Tim, when you're running, do you have AirPods in?
Are you listening to music? Are you listening to... Rarely, sometimes. I'm kind of zen on that. I got into it, you know, and then I got into the Garmin watch, and then I got in on the timing and, you know, how fast my miles were. Oh, look, he's looking for freebie now. But I kind of let that go and I kind of run by feel trying to get into it and I do think there's something and especially like when I'm in Minneapolis, I got a state trooper but just it's pretty calm.
They're running behind or whatever. Folks who run leave their, I'm convinced of this, dog folks and runners, they leave politics out of it because they know it's your time. So it's really refreshing that people talk to you like a runner, not like you're the governor or something. So like, you know, looking good or whatever. Do you have a favorite subject that you do like to talk
about that is not politics? Like, are you a sport, I know you're a sports guy, but like you love talking about the Vikings or the Cornhuskers or whatever it is, or reality television, or what do you like to talk about that's kind of nice and silly? Yeah, I think cars. I grew up at a time, you guys are a little younger than me,
this whole cars thing, we were much more into it. The Pixar movie? I remember. I'm kidding. I apologize for him. So, but I just think like classic cars. I've never really owned that many, but you know the cars you have. I watched the cars I used for him. So, but I just think like classic cars, I've never really owned that many, but you know the cars you have.
I watched the cars I used to own, you know I grew up in high school and had a beautiful Camaro, you know, at the time, and then I traded it for a Honda Civic. And now you watch these auction shows and I'm like, damn it, that car's worth $80,000 now. And I traded it for a Honda Civic worth two grand. Exactly.
I had, my mom gave me this, like, I kicked and screamed in high school, I'm like, please can I just have a car. She brought me like a $200 car, it had like rust all over it. And my friend Reyna, you know Reyna, these guys know Reyna, she called it Grease Lightning, and she's like, you're taking Grease Lightning
to school today. Now what about, are you really into the sound of a combustion engine, or are you into the sound of a combustion engine or are you are you in into the? Sound of an electric engine the clean power of an electric Look whole spectrum the whole spectrum of this I I was in I was in Phoenix for It was a governor's event or whatever and there's folks there displaying their wares and the lucid folks were there. Yeah. Oh, yeah and the Lucid folks were there with their fastest production car ever. You put any Lamborghini out there, this thing,
and it was like inside a spaceship. Oh, this thing's like 1.8 seconds in the quarter. I mean, it's zero to 60. It's unbelievable. And it's like a whole new world. And I have never yet owned a fully electric, but they're fascinating. So, yeah. I'm so excited. and I have never yet owned a fully electric, but they are fascinating.
Yeah, they're the best. I love it. I'm so excited that every single car brand now has a fully electric car, and I don't want to throw undue shade towards Mr. Musk, but I got to tell you, his politics is, I got rid of my Tesla. I feel like I'm driving around a Trump sticker
with that car, so it's gone, and I'm now enjoying a Trump sticker with that car. So it's gone and I'm now enjoying. You mean the crypto, I call it the crypto truck. It's just, anyway. Well, here's my thing. This is for me. And I said, my thing, my prize possession is that I've had it for a long time. I got a 79 international harvester.
You know, they used to give these things away. Scout, Scout 2. There you go. Look, you guys hear that? These things. But yeah, these things are, you used to get it if you bought a tractor, they threw in the Scout for you. It was an original SUV.
Yeah, there was a, back in the late 70s. So mine was right before they went out of business. It was 1979. They were the precursors of SUVs, but here's the deal. 40 years ago at the end of October is when they closed. They were made in Fort Wayne, Indiana. So on that date this year, they're announcing the new Scout bringing it back fully electric.
Come on. No kidding. So an international harvester Scout, that famous name, name is back, Volkswagen bought it. And so they're launching that thing. So I mean, that's the stuff I talk about. And yeah, it's the car stuff, because it's back, Volkswagen bought it. And so they're launching that thing. That's the stuff I talk about, and it's the car stuff. You've got to go do Dax Shepard's podcast, because he'll talk to you for three days about cars. I love these guys, and the guys who are so smart tell me how to do it.
Look, I'm Tinker on the edges. These are guys that can replace a transmission. I love that. I said when I get done with this, I'm going to go back to community college and learn body work. Just a sense of accomplishment that you can fix your own vehicle, you can put on a new quarter panel, you can paint it. Sean, you took body work in high school, right?
Like a lot of reiki and stuff like that. Yeah. If you broke down on the side of the road, are you one of those guys that can just pop the hood and look under there and kind of look around and see like, oh, there's the problem. Yeah, some of it, some of it I can't. But look, on these new ones,
I don't even know how to open the hood. I will say that. I sound like I'm the old guy, these newfangled. But the cars that you used to be able to do, my kids, it would blow their mind like some of the stuff we could fix, like my vehicle's overheating. I said, oh, it's the thermostat.
And you'd show them how to take it out, put it in boiling water, pop the thermostat. I was going to say, kids don't know that stuff anymore. They don't, and there's some, Jason calls his agent if he gets a flat tire. Yeah, so. You know. So, I mean, and that's the truth.
I mean, you need to know the truth about this guy. But, I mean, he's a Hollywood elitist, liberal elitist. But, but. I'm on the corner of Stunston Boulevard. But honestly, if me, like if my car starts to go do-do-do-do, and say a Hollywood elitist, liberal elitist. But honestly, if my car starts to go, I'm pulling over and I'm like, I don't know what's going on. Yeah, I have no idea, yeah, same.
Makes you feel powerless. I said, I think, Joe and my kids, some of these things that you can try and repair, I like doing it. Now look, we all know that's also very, very dangerous because I don't know sometimes and I start taking stuff apart and then you're like,
well, here's six extra screws and there's no idea where they're going. There's a bit of that with me. So. Yeah, for sure. Now speaking of your kids, which one of them or you or your wife gets most pissed off when somebody calls you Waltz instead of Walls?
Yeah. Yeah, my daughter probably. Yeah, it's a whole new wave of it now, right? Yeah. Like what are people's problems? Walls. Yeah, there's no tea. Yeah, there's no tea.
It seems pretty easy that, but you know, in all fairness, probably when we immigrated from Germany, they probably dropped the tea. Well, this is the last wave of it. Like you cannot get more famous than you are now. So everyone in the South finally got it. I guarantee it.
Yes, tell me what that, I know this is like a stock answer, but I really want to know what that feeling was like and the reaction when you got the call from Kamala. I mean, that was so wild. Well, you know the story, in typical me fashion, I missed the first one. Sure, you did? Well, I thought it was like, you was like a car warranty call coming in,
so I didn't take it. And truly, no one knew. Like this was her decision, and that Tuesday morning, no one knew, and then I got another call and said, "'Pick up your damn phone,' and then called back." Your warranty may be expiring. It was overwhelming, it was an incredible privilege,
but I heard you guys talking, and I listened to the Ted Danson Woody Harrelson piece about imposter syndrome. Just trust me, when the Vice President of the United States calls you and said you're on the ticket with me, it sinks in. So I- Pretty cool, yeah, fast. Fast.
Have you allowed yourself to really imagine and start to build a possible wish list of things that you would like to be given the reins to when you guys win? Well, this is one, and I think it's just your mental health of compartmentalizing things. Still focused on this final stretch that's ahead of us, still thinking about that.
I trust the vice president will make her decision on that. I said, I wasn't interviewing for a job when I talked to her. I said, use my skillsets. If you need to plunk me in Omaha to win one vote, send me there. Just what I would have helped. And I think she, and it feels really right to me. She talks about a kid from Oakland,
a kid from Nebraska, middle class kids, kind of complimentary things. We've lived different lives, but we have the same values. So I would assume she would know. middle-class kids, kind of complementary things. We've lived different lives, but we have the same values. So I would assume she would know. My passion is kids and teaching and education. And that's it. We'll be right back.
And now back to the show. We were just talking with somebody recently about this idea of getting nervous when you're putting it in a position like this and getting a call from the vice president saying, hey, you're on the ticket. Makes you probably makes you feel nervous. But I wonder if when something like this happens, it's almost like a thing that you can't even dream about, at least certainly I couldn't.
So it's almost like you can't get even nervous because it's so far beyond what you, I can get nervous about things that I think about doing, but if something comes that's new. No, that's a great, that's a great analogy. I mean, think of that day, this was a Tuesday morning, we got the call, within 20 minutes my life changed. I said I'm minding my own damn business at home and all of a sudden it blows up.
It should be noted, Tim, I did turn it down. I was the first call and then Tim was the second call. Oh, Sean. I'm just, we're being honest. But they sweep in, you've got all these folks around you, they pack your clothes for you and tell you, you go in and get on a private plane, which is, I've never flown on a private plane to do this,
so they fly you to Philadelphia. That's funny, cause, hey, Jason's never not. Yeah. I wish. I was waiting for it. Well, they take you to Philadelphia. That's funny, cause, Dave, Jason's never not. Yeah. I wish. I was waiting for it. Well, they take you to Philadelphia, and then I also, and I told them when they were interviewing me, I said,
look, I've never given a speech off a teleprompter. I speak and it, look, it has its problems, and I told them that. You'll get about 90% good, and then you'll get 10% stuff you'll have to clean up. That's me, cause that's how I talk. But they sent me there, they put me in the back of a college locker room, and they had mocked up
the stage I was going to go on in about an hour, and put the speech on the teleprompter. And so I practiced it a little bit, and then I'm standing at that door in Philadelphia, like 12, 15,000 people waiting to see the vice president in this announcement. She and her standing out on the curtain, and she's like, you know, well, get this right.
And so it opened up and that's what it was. But no, you're right. I think your analysis is right. It was just too big to get nervous about it. I didn't have time to think about it. You didn't seem, when you came out, he was so terrific and it felt like, here we go. Honestly, Tim, it really felt like, here we go.
We are entering into a new age, and thank God Tim is the guy, and Tim is here. And there are a lot of other great candidates, for sure. And that authenticity, and that genuine joy, and happiness, and privilege that you must be feeling, it comes through, and it's just so damn refreshing. Was it hard for you to maintain that down to earth personality, which you clearly have,
when you got into politics, where most of your fellow politicians either have to be or have learned to be overly polished and slick. Is it disheartening for you to be around so many colleagues that are like that? It's just, you're so refreshing. Well, it's a different approach. And I always say this, that I never,
and honest to God, I never thought about running for office. I have a whole life before this, teaching, National Guard, in my community, and things like that. But I think my life prepared me well. And so I approach like, look, you have got to be pretty self-aware in my community and things like that. This isn't a special thing that you've been granted. Your job is to work for people. And I try and approach it like,
I was hired to teach kids in school, so I need to do my best job. You know, that I can publicize. And I've been hired to be a representative. And I took great pride that I was very bipartisan. I, you know, this idea that we can't figure things out. My staff, we always had a saying that, you know, if the facts dispute our ideology, we change our ideology.
It's that simple. You're not married to it. So a lot of times I don't have an ideological dog in a fight. It's just what the facts show. And I think trying to approach these things like problem solving, you're working with people, you're trying to do your best, I'll be the first to admit it has been really challenging
with Donald Trump. You know, I won a congressional race in 2016. Donald Trump won my district by double digits, nearly 20%. You know, I won a congressional race in 2016. Donald Trump won my district by double digits, nearly 20%. So thousands of people voted for Donald Trump and me on that, that was only a few years ago. Now would that be true today? Probably not, they've continued to. But I think trying to focus on what the job is,
that it's a humbleness and it's not your whole identity. I watch these folks try and hang on to these jobs and things like that, like it's everything. If the folks don't want me to do it, they won't do it, but I'm telling you, here's what we can do. Yeah. You know, Tim, first of all, I hope, and congrats, and I really do hope that your run, as you say,
you were a high school teacher and a coach and you had no sort of political aspirations. I hope that you deciding to do it inspires other people like you, who are leaders in their community and who aren't looking to enrich themselves, who aren't looking for anything other than to serve. I hope that inspires other people to do what you've done,
because that's what we need. I meet hundreds every day. Who should? They won't, they won't though, because of the money and because of what they're afraid will happen if they get into it. And because of things like social media and their lives will get upended and all that.
And security. Yeah, we were speaking of the overwhelming thing on this back during that debate. They drove me through Times Square to see my picture up on those big screens and so somebody said, you look nervous. No kidding, I'm sitting there freaking out on this thing. But I'm honest to God, before things went live,
I'm standing there and I'm like, there's 345 million people in this country and it's me and this dude, that is just not right. And it's true, I mean, it's kind of overwhelming, but that kind of got rid of my imposter syndrome and said, look, I know that I know what's right, I know who I am, I'm trying to be right. I just go back to your values and if you leave.
So Will's point is this, that I do hope people do this. I do hope they get out there because we need them. We need good people. So I was gonna say, and then you, what do you think it was when you talk about having a guy like Donald Trump getting double digits in your district, what do you think it was that allowed people to convince themselves that that he would
be you know when I see that they you know these top unions are deciding like well we don't know if we can endorse an actual candidate this year because they're worried about their membership union union member. Imagine this union members who want to support Donald Trump the guy who wants to do nothing, who has nothing but disregard for them. It's staggering. And I'm sure I could get a million comments back on this. Somebody on one of our social pages, people would say, hey, if you aren't at,
you don't know what you're talking about. First of all, I have had lots of real jobs, so I say right back at you. But also, this is a guy who doesn't have any regard for the American family, doesn't have any regard for hardworking people, doesn't have any regard, would bust a union as quicker than you can imagine. So what is it about that, that they've been able to fool these people? Yeah. And rank and file union members, one thing,
look, the leadership in unions, that's more political than what I'm doing. They have to cover their butt on their things. And I'm as frustrated as you are on this, Will. But the one thing I do think about, you wonder what happened. The first thing I think of, there's not something wrong with my constituents.
These are good people trying to go to work and do things. And like the New York Times sends somebody out every few weeks to interview a guy at a bar and figure out what happened to rural America. These are my family. I've lived there. I do think one of the things, I always said this as a teacher,
if I would give an exam or something and a majority of students would not do well, probably had a little something to do with me in there was I not getting it across. And so I think some of it is how we message this. I don't think that's the full blame on it. Certainly Donald Trump is a master of manipulation, a master of what new media look like.
But I do think there's some ways, is what are we not doing to appeal to those rank? Look, I'm a union member, I think. That's what I did. And I get a lot of union support, but I know there's some rank and file members. And so they're not monolithic, it's not their only issue, but I say this, and I'm kind of with you on this, Will,
the rest of it is you don't have to worry about all the rest of that stuff if you're not in a union because you're not going to get paid as well, you're not going to have a pension, you may not have healthcare. You better focus on the things that matter, stay in your lane. And so they've done a good job of distracting on things
that are the cultural war stuff rather than the bread and butter. Right, right. Well, you know, it seems like if those folks were slightly more sort of curious or discerning when it comes to news, information, facts, maybe they wouldn't make that decision and maybe they would be more prone to vote for you guys instead of him.
Can you as a teacher attract that back or attribute that to something that we're not doing right in schools? To sort of, and you know, because I just feel like it's just common sense to me, it seems like there's a clear choice for everyone in this country. If you just want to take just preserving democracy alone, who to vote for, but all these, these smaller issues, it does seem like pretty easy. If you just look a little bit further than, you know, Fox News or whatever, you would see, oh, all the facts are on the side of
going this direction instead of that direction. And maybe does it start at schools? Well, this may be, but this is where I think Vice President Harris is focusing really rightly. This idea of middle class doesn't sound like anything so groundbreaking, but this idea of housing and down payment assistance, this idea of cost now, this idea of middle class doesn't sound like anything so groundbreaking, but this idea of housing and down payment assistance, this idea of cost now, this idea of child tax credit, because the one thing I will say, Jason, on this is,
is that these guys on the other side have created an economy which many of the people you're talking about are busting their ass just to get by. They don't have time to spend a lot on this. They're trying to figure out how to afford childcare. They're trying to figure out how to make things work. They see inflationary prices go up, and we may say, look, inflation is higher
everywhere else in the world. They don't care about that, because that's impacting with them. They hear a guy like JD Vance say, egg prices went up. Yeah, because of bird flu. They don't care about bird flu, they just know egg prices went up. So I do think there's a part,
certainly discerning on media is something my wife used to teach a course on modern media, language and logic, trying to think through that. But I think part of it is these guys have, as we're saying on this, they've shifted wealth to the point where the wealth gap is staggering. When you see it in a graphic, people can't believe how truly bad it is. And what's stuck on that is a whole bunch of people trying to get through their lives and Donald Trump has told them, you know where to put the blame rather than that So I'd gap the gap the wealth gap the wealth gap has never been is never been bigger and never and I remember saying this Ten twenty years ago how that gap was widening one and now we're at this place
And if if people think for one minute that Donald Trump and JD Vance give two craps about the middle class, they're looking to do tax cut to the richest Americans, to these billionaires to give tax cuts to those. When the people who need the tax cuts are the people right in the middle who drive this country, who have made this country what it is. When you do that, Minnesota is listed as, you know, the Republicans always say it's a high tax data. We're home to many Fortune 500 companies,
high concentration, but we have what's rated as the fairest tax system. It's a progressive tax system. If you don't make as much, you don't pay as much. If you make more, you pay more. Look what ends up happening that. Top five business state, top three place to raise kids, top place for healthcare, longest longevity.
Look, we're not perfect, I mean, and it's cold as hell here in the winter, so there's things that happen. But I thought you controlled the weather according to Marjorie Taylor Greene. Yeah, if we did, it would not be 40 below up here. Right. But you're right, this idea of making the case
to people that this works, and look, this isn't class, they said you're engaging class warfare, they already won the war almost on that, the guy's on the other side. But this is about sense of fairness and it's stunning to me that I thought one of the, my killer lines in this that the middle class would say, do you think it's fair Donald Trump doesn't pay tax?
That doesn't seem fair. And a lot of people are like, well, he's successful, he knows how to work the system. That's disappointing to me. Work the system. I imagine, put it this way, if my dad gave me $400 million, I'd be a hell of a lot richer than Donald Trump is. I guarantee you would.
I know. Absolutely. You could have put it in a CD. 80%. Exactly, I might touch it. What do you think would be the best way or easiest way to penetrate that bubble that they all seem to be firmly inside of as far as giving them the information that they need
and could sway their vote. Like, do you literally have to go to town hall meetings in some of these deep red districts? Does it mean being on Fox News a little bit more often? Like, how do you get to them? Yeah, I think that's right. We have folks, Pete Buttigieg goes on Fox News quite a bit. He's one of our best spokespeople.
You've been on it too. Yeah, and go on and just talk to folks, because I don't think we can assume that all of them are not there. Like the Vice President making that case, getting out there, going to places. We're going into some of these pretty red areas, and this is another one of the vice president's things
that I think when they feel this and people can see it, we're getting off a bus tour in rural Pennsylvania and one side of the street has our supporters and the other side of the street's not. I said they always make it easy for us, they're all in the same hat so we can see and we know who they are. But she didn't blink and it wasn't performance art.
The only people there were her husband and my wife and I. And she said, Tim, don't ever forget, we work just as hard for folks on this side of the street as on the other side of the street. You start to see some of the results of that and we're seeing it in Minnesota. It's pretty hard. Like the vice president's advocating
for this child tax credit. We implement it on the state level, lowers childhood poverty. Some of this stuff starts to make sense. And you have to, I'm a school teacher, so I talk Maslow's hierarchy, you know, you can't get to self-actualization about things if people are worried about their safety
and their hunger and things like that. Show people that these policies help make them more money. People are willing to tackle climate change if their lights come on and their bills don't go up. They don't care where the power comes from. In fact, most people would rather see it come from renewables. But I think sometimes we say,
well, why can't you see we have to save the planet on this? How about we just create a whole bunch of new union jobs like they did with this proposal, whole bunch of opportunities. That's a great, it's interesting. One of the things that I noticed about you and Vice President Harris is that the way that you guys talk,
that sort of antidote you gave by the Vice President talking about we work for all Americans, there is that sense on, that a lot of the people who vote Republican talk about red, blue, blah, blah, blah. You guys don't talk as much about that. You guys talk about all Americans. The divisiveness. Because, yeah, you have to, right?
I mean, we're all here, we all live here, we all, you know. And I think secretly we all want to get along. Of course we do. Yes, I think we all really want to. Human survival. Yeah. I mean, there is a sort of a fun kind of this team, that team sort of, I mean, just speaking to you as a coach,
and I'm a big sports fan too, like, there's a lot of fun being on one side versus the other, and you kind of watch the scoreboard and then like the standings throughout the year. But that people are bringing this now into politics is literally dangerous at this point. And so like if they could just get a little bit more into their local team and stop being so sort of tribal
and competitive and just think about this unity a little bit more. I'll tell you, Jason, as a, I'm a geographer by training, I love maps except one. Whoever built the red blue map did more damage than you would ever imagine. Because you look at that map and you look at South Dakota and say, oh, South Dakota's all red or whatever.
That's not true. That is not true. There's a mix. Or even you look at an urban area and say, well, that's blue, everybody in there. That's not true. That is not true. There's a mix. Or even you look at an urban area and say, well, that's blue, everybody in there. That's not true either. And they created this false mindset for us because it's very visual.
Yeah, it's a good note for the newscasters. They should, instead of having that big map during election time, they should literally split each state into blue and red, just to show the percentages, rather than color at one color. I just want to go on the record as saying, just out of deference to you, Tim, and what you're doing in the office that you're seeking,
that I have withheld a really good joke because it was in really poor taste. We'll get it in the wrap up, Will. I'll do it in the wrap up, but I just wanted you to know that. That's how much respect I have for you. Is it about me? Yes, of course.
But I could also make it about Jason too. I could, I could. There's plenty there. There's plenty. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. You know, for me, one of the issues that I want to get to, and sorry if this seems very abrupt,
but I think the issue for me that needs to be taken head on and we need to talk about, and I can't believe that there's any debate in talking about it considering that it's 2024, is women's healthcare. Yep, yeah, absolutely. For me, it is number one this year. Women's healthcare, and we, the fact that it's even up for debate
is absolutely ridiculous. I couldn't agree more. Look, there's household names now of women who should have been able to have their own private healthcare kept to themselves, who are thrust into the national light because they had to go through horrific situations, that should have been as simple as health care being delivered. And look, this is something that's taken a while, and I think for all of us on here, men need to know how to talk about it,
men need to know how women's bodies work and how doctors understand that. And I think that's something that has changed. I agree with you. I said, while back in the debate, it took a long time for them to get around to two most important issues, the issue of women's bodily autonomy and the democracy. Seems like those would have been two questions
to come out of the chute with. What's that great quote or question from Kamala Harris to one of the Supreme Court people about, can you think of a law that does the same for a male body? And it's like, there it is, it's all in that question. It is that simple. And everything stems from that. And these guys are not gonna stop.
I talk about it, the whole, they're all over us. I don't wanna have to talk with my wife and I infertility issues and trying to use I.U.I. And there isn't a person out there, there isn't a woman out there who's seeking healthcare, who's doing, who wants to talk about it or is in a position who feels good about doing it. Nobody's going out there.
That's the other thing is like, you know, abortion right or whatever. Do you think people are, this is something that everybody's looking for? That this is a place that people are in a great place in their life? I'm with you, Will. Who's asking for this agenda?
Yeah, exactly. Who's asking for tax cuts for billionaires? Who's asking to repress women on this? I said this, dude. You think the guy said- A bunch of men. So they go- Rich men. Well, you think they're sitting around in the bar in Wisconsin saying, you know what we really need to do?
We need to ban Orwell's books and we need to give billionaires a tax cut and we need to repress women. Let's hope not. I hope they're talking about we need better jobs. We need to make sure I can't afford to pay for daycare. Tackle these issues. And I think this is what Kamala's putting out.
Let's really tackle the issues and show them that we're going after these things. But you know when we start to do that, they don't want to talk about it because they got a plan. Listening to them talk about healthcare, listening to Donald Trump ramble about protecting pre-existing conditions, it's terrifying to me if you want to be president of the United States or vice president, you should at least have a working knowledge how insurance works and how healthcare
works. And they don't. You should have a working knowledge of how anything works. Yeah. It's absurd. If we ever wanted to have a real conversation and you had to remove the word salad and you were like, no, you had, the moment you deviate from the question, you're out,
it would be- Or that an injection of bleach is just not a real good remedy for anything that ails you. You know, that should be pretty simple. But it is why I have alabaster skin. Listen, I want to ask you something. You know, just as a sidebar, Tim, when you first came on the scene,
you started talking about that program, you started in Minnesota about free lunches in schools. That blew my mind because my mom raised five kids by herself as the youngest, and I would go to school and I wouldn't have lunch. I just wouldn't eat. We didn't have the money. We didn't have food.
We're sure made up for it. Pretty hard to learn. You're all caught up, Sean. Pump it. It's just crazy we don't come in and ask them, where's your money for the heat today? We put new windows in the schools, where's your money for the heat today? We put new windows in the schools, where's your money kid?
To have this idea. And look, it's that simple philosophy of investing. Every dollar you invest in early childhood, you get 12 back. Yes, I love that. Where did you get all that growing up? Where did you get this drive to be this servant of like, and by the way, thank you for all your service,
your public service. Well, I think about it and I, you know, when you're older it's a lot of things that come in certainly from parents and small community, but I gotta be honest with you. I grew up Catholic and at that time it was about service and the Catholic nuns, you know, get the little thump in the back of the head
thinking you're too big for your own riches. And it really was New Testament to the least amongst this type of stuff. I don't talk about, you don't need people to give you a sermon in elected office, but try and live one a little bit. Try and do something. And I think it was from that.
I feel very blessed by that. And it's different now. My wife converted me to Lutheranism, which is basically Catholicism with more singing, but that's about the difference. But it's the same type of principle, so I think that's what it was. And again, we have a saying, we have a great senator who died way too early
in Paul Wellstone who said, we all do better when we all do better. And it's this sense of servant leadership, this sense of putting back in. And you benefit, and we keep talking about this, this school meals piece of it. You get better achievement, you get better students in school. And so even if you remove the moral we keep talking about this, this school meals piece of it. You get better achievement, you get better students
in school, and so even if you remove the moral aspect of feeding a child, you actually save money. So if you're just heartless and don't want to pay higher taxes, you save, you get $12 return on that. So I said the simplification is, you can buy school buses and school meals, or you can buy prison buses and prison meals. You make the decision where you want to invest,
and it's much better. Yeah, that's great. of course it makes so much sense to invest in the future, to invest in ourselves, to invest in our kids. That's what's gonna help us. Because otherwise if it rots beneath, if that doesn't get supported, then there is no future. That's right.
And public schools for all of us are it. This is in rural areas they keep thinking about, these folks who wanna voucherize. So you're gonna have your voucher, so here's your voucher, you get a small tax credit or whatever, but your public school closes. Where are you gonna send them?
Where's that in private school when you're out in a town like I was a 400? The idea that the community invested, and I had wonderful public school teachers who were teaching in a small school with 20 kids in a class, coming every day prepared to do that, what a sense of investment they all made.
And I think from that kind of servant leadership, but watching the people around me, the old Mr. Rogers thing, when you need somebody to find the helper, the helpers were all over and they were doing this. There's some of that. I love that. I used to, just talking to you, like Jason said earlier,
you're just so, I can see you as a teacher. I mean, I didn't have you as a teacher, but you remind me of like, you seem like the greatest teacher ever where all the kids just effing love you. Well, it's a privilege of my life. Now my wife said, I was the fun teacher and she's the teacher that kids came back 10 years later
and say thank you for teaching me English. And so Mr. Walsh was a barrel of fun, but I learned English. Do you guys have a similar dynamic in parenting? Is she the disciplinarian and you're kind of the fun guy? Yeah, she's amazing. If you've seen her and she can do anything, she is just the quintessential Lutheran Minnesota woman.
Yeah, and she's great. We're partners in this. I feel blessed that we got together. But just to be clear, she was much more political than me early. She would watch the conventions. I'm like, I'm not watching the conventions. It's summer, I'm going golfing or something.
She paid attention. She knew it all. I didn't, she knew who people were. I'm like, I don't know who the senator from North Carolina is. And she would know them all. So Tim, let me ask you this. You're a coach, you're a teacher, but you're a coach. And I love the idea that you're coaching teams and I just think you'd be awesome. It's, you know, we're looking at the clock. It's two we got two minutes left in this election and the team
Which is America's at the sideline. What are you saying? What are you saying to us? What do we need to do to kind of you know? To get a W here for our country. Yeah, I've been I've been given just in the election, but in general for America Look, it's a privilege. I mean, I wish we weren't in this situation. I wish this thing were a blowout It's not gonna be it's gonna come down to the, I wish we weren't in this situation. I wish this thing were a blowout. It's not gonna be. It's gonna come down to the hard work. But the sense of privilege here,
this isn't about the next four years. This is about the next 40. And you're hearing from your people you know around the world. The rest of the world's looking for us to do the right thing here. And I think to be a part of that and everybody to be the little things they can do,
whether it's door knocking, whether it's going on and giving what little they have, donations that people give, 10 bucks, that's a lot for a lot of people. They do something else and they give the help. I think it's this idea that you can be part of something bigger and that's what people want. That's the whole thing about teams.
Like the kids who enjoyed being on football teams were the most, is the kid who got in on kickoffs because you're going to play everybody. He wasn't the best athlete maybe, but that kid was there because he was with his buddies. He was with his team. And I think for Americans, this idea we can be in this, we don't have to agree, and I'm not naive.
This is tough. There's folks that don't agree on anything. But I think the vast majority of people realize it doesn't need to be this way. And I give Kamala Harris full credit. This idea of joy, and I watched the Wall Street Journal poo poo joy. I'll take joy over being like crabby and awful and no one wants to be around you. That's what she's doing and politics can be that way.
Look, Donald Trump wants to make it, it would be easier I guess he's saying is just elect one person forever and let them make the decisions. This democracy stuff is hard, it's messy, it's difficult and it's frustrating, but it's the best that's been devised. Yeah, and it's the best path towards community.
And we'll let you go, but I wanna ask you, sort of building on that notion of community and everybody coming together, and after you guys win, what do you think might possibly be a big give that you and Kamala could possibly offer to the folks who didn't vote for you guys, that we get them so happy or so comfortable that they would feel good about uniting
with the rest of the country, getting back to a bit more. Other than they'll get more jobs and they'll save for life. Right, but that notion of kind of becoming one big happy family and like not just the standard speech about, you know, I want to be president for all of that, but something maybe taken directly
from the Republican platform or their agenda that would be felt as that give or that offer that would come across and have the effectiveness of like an olive branch. Thought about that. Well, she said it and I agree with her. She needs to appoint a Republican to the cabinet. I do think it matters to her, to a position of authority.
And look, there's a lot of them out there. These folks who are coming out and speaking on behalf of these Republicans, I disagree with many of them. Their values are there. I served with these people. People like Jeff Flake, the Senator from Arizona, super conservative, but that man is as honest as anything.
I've dealt with him. Jim Langford, who wrote the big piece of the immigration bill. I served with him. That guy is the most conservative person I ever met, but he's big piece of the immigration bill. That they killed, yeah. I served with him. That guy is the most conservative person I ever met, but he's also one of the most honorable. Some of these people need to be put in a position
where they truly have the ability to influence things. That's awesome. Because they are ethical and they care about this country. And I think that's something that really sets her apart to make a high profile appointment to the county. Or two, or three. Yes, bring them, folks who care about the country. And let us, look, I don't want to be surrounded by people.
In my organization, my folks know that I'll say something. They say, you know, with all due respect, governor, that is a horrible idea and we should not do it. And I'm like, okay, good, thank you for stopping me from doing that horrible idea. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think I need to know this. Like giving away SUVs with every tractor.
That was a horrible idea. I need to know before you leave what kind of snacks are on the plane or the car or the truck. What settles you? Yeah, this just irritates, and I don't do it to irritate my pescatarian daughter. A beef jerky is my thing. Sure.
I'm a homemade beef jerky, and Pete Buttigieg's in-laws made some and he brought me some. And I like the idea of a friend bringing you homemade beef jerky and know that that pleases you more than anything. So that's my thing. All right, well, listen, we just can't thank you enough for the trust to sit with us and your time.
We're such big fans and we wish you the best of luck and safety out there on the trail. And bring us that W. We're gonna do everything we can and just couldn't be more thrilled that you're a part of this. Thank all three of you. We are really honored and your authentic self
just shines through and that authenticity is just so refreshing and great. Yeah, this was big deal for me, you guys. Thank you for having me on. I'm a big fan and appreciate all you're doing. Yeah, I like it. We really appreciate it. Thank you, Tim.
Thanks, guys. Bye, yeah. Have a great day. That was great, thank you. You guys are the best. Hey, I didn't get in on this. I heard you guys often when you're talking, you're talking the golf stuff. This is a thing, honest to God,
I don't know if you know this. So I grew up in that really small town. Yeah. Sand green golf, three bucks green feed. You know it? I know about it. What is sand green golf? Oh, you gotta hear this.
This is so exciting. So set it up again so people know. So you grew up in Nebraska. I did, small town. And you played golf there. Played golf, and like everybody played golf, farmers, everybody, and it wasn't country club golf, it was sand green golf.
And what it is is the greens are made out of sand and they're oiled with vegetable oil. Well in the old days they were oiled with oil, which was not good. I think this is what they do in the Middle East. In Australia. You rake the green with a path and then you putt and then you rake it again to put ridges in it.
And they're little like postage stamp sized greens, but it's a whole different game. But I hear you guys talk a lot about golf. You've got to get on a sand green golf course. Listen, listen, once you've won and you want to take a little break, Jason and I will meet you in Nebraska. Let's go play some sand green golf.
I'm working even harder now. We gotta work. Okay, okay. We're gonna find ya. All right, thanks fellas. Thanks, man. Thank you, sir. Let's get her done.
Yeah, absolutely. Bye, Tim. Thank you, pal. Boy, that fella, I mean, he, Really cool. He gives politicians a good name, in my opinion. Yes, in my opinion as well. I'm with you.
You immediately, he's the dad I always wanna. And I know that there are a lot of people out there who don't want, and I, so I get you saying in my opinion, but the one thing you can't knock is the guy's authenticity. Yeah. He's just such an authentic, real person and it's great talking to him. How can you not like that guy?
I'm sure you can disagree with some of his policies, I'm sure, but I'm so excited about the prospect of simply just having somebody represent me and the country I love, that I'm not sort of worrying about them saying something mean, nasty, offensive. I just, he's just like a guy I like to call my representative. I'm just, I would be proud of that. And also not a guy who's out there to enrich himself
or protect himself and use the office as a way to avoid prosecution. Right? Yeah, I mean, truly, truly. It's just so not self-serving, it's the opposite. It's public service, right? Yeah, the truth. And he's so, yeah, it's pretty,
I think the most jarring thing was seeing Mike Terry there at the end, who works with us, our producers, that he was actually in the room. Yeah, that he was there with Tim Waldo. Yeah, interesting, very interesting. But I like him a lot. Did you guys have any questions that you didn't get to that you wanted to?
I wanted to mention this thing that there have been some fake fundraising emails that were going out. This is true. Oh, yeah. Yes. That he was gonna be asking about. But we get these fake ones that are coming from them and they wanted to address them
and I think they're working on it. Oh really? Yeah. It's gonna be hard to track. I wanna know like. There's a lot of awful people out there. I wanna know what like bad TV shows he watches. I wanted to know like if he has like a little game on his phone that when he has a little game on his phone
that when he has a little quiet moment, like we do with like Wordle or something, I bet he's got something fun in there. Something really silly. Candy Crush is it? Yeah, he's got a pretty full plate these days. I know, but you've got to like, two minutes to like.
You have to be able to, yeah, exactly. Even if it's just like going into the bathroom and like just sitting down, you know, like not even like taking your pants down, but just like hiding in a stall somewhere just to get some quiet. Yeah, yeah. Right, right, I know.
Oh, I know how he feels. Oh, I can't go anywhere. I know it, sweetheart. Oh, but isn't that a good idea though, you guys, to do, to you know, Fox, CNN, it doesn't matter who you are, to split, instead of showing a map of this is all red, this is all blue state, just cut it in half
and show us the percentages of each. Well, they do actually. Oh yes. The great Steve Kornacki will go in there and he will zoom in and it will expand and you will see sort of the micro of each of these districts and states and you will see how it is sort of split up inside there. All right, fine.
Yeah, it's true. Also, those maps are so deceiving because when you look at, when you put it up against population, Yeah, it's always different. Where population is centered. Ah, it's the electoral college. What are you gonna do?
How are we gonna get centered on the electoral college. So what are you gonna do? Yeah, yeah. How are we gonna get rid of that electoral college? Yeah, we can't do it here from our stupid ass podcast. You know, we need smart folks. I know, I know. We can't. And they're a button. And we're on our way, hopefully.
You know what I wanna say to the electoral college? Uh oh, here it comes, Willie. Bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Bye! Rob Armjarf and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.